hey guys I'm riding right an illicit be
crazy I'm gonna watch the Luigi death
stare with ELISA right oh no wait do you
know what that is thank you
have you seen it I have it I know what
it in okay yes all right let's do it
I don't know what it is let's find out
a little slow in this random
ah
[ __ ] big perfect first off I want to
give this guy super major powers
ah that's a fun video as a fun video you
know what that makes me want to go to a
con with you yeah we should do an
intercept you should we could we could
play dress-up and other places too you
know I mean ah I'm talking real plain
during sex you know I mean that's what I
was referring to let's just keep it to
cons okay okay okay yeah that sounds of
this video uh these guys have balls you
know yeah I got balls like real [ __ ]
balls like I would know kind of you know
I love how many people they pissed off I
know I'm like oh my people Channel got
bad I like people who think it's funny
to piss off other people just so they
could get it on camera that is hilarious
that video totally connected with me can
we seriously just talk about how this
guy's like legitimately on a cart like
it's a moving thing like his feet are up
there he's not moving out with any
petals he's like actually driving it how
where did he get such a device cuz I
want one yeah who the [ __ ] are you it's
probably an engineer yeah it's really
sophisticated in there I went in many
years of college just like oh I can
throw this turtle shell well anyway guys
um if you're new to the channel and
Alyssa has a channel to check it out
yeah Alyssa be crazy one word but if you
type in the words individually you'll
still get a lot of respect I don't know
why that is who knows you guys probably
know I just oblivious that's okay though
because you know you should still click
it see the things all the things and all
these things all those things cuz
together these things create amazing
things what I just did was what some
people might call hilarious you should
write a book on how to be funny I should
I have
I already started did you sorry yeah did
I figure up it comes down to five basic
principles oh okay
the penis uh-huh the vagina penis and
vagina together penis and penis vagina
vagina I find that really hard for one
person to do all by themselves so as a
single person you're saying it's really
really hard to be funny
no I'm just saying you have to talk
about those things Oh see now see what
he doesn't clarify so that's where
people like that's where the wit comes
in over the eye I really need to rethink
my life right now I mean I thought
always being funny all this time but I
never talk about those things that's why
you're not funny
dang it oh I need rethink my whole
strategy we could do this over sex see
penis and vagina see how links that's
what makes it fun let's do some shout
outs
I like shout outs Jim Jarra give me a
shout-out please
well ginger oh that's cool JJ it's JJ
Abrams that's what the JJ stands for we
just blew your cover dude dear JJ
Abrams's subscribes to the real rejects
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I'm huge people here
that's what she said funny
hey big penis joke okay Jim Jarrah
you're the man okay you keep that slim
jim don't keep it slim you know you
don't want to call the slim jim his
penis Steven McLoughlin and if Laura
could provide the vocals all Lauren's
like here right now that I'll make sure
I'm gonna screenshot this for you buddy
to make sure she gets it what am I not
good enough
apparently not cheese hey dude we just
almost Oh handsome waiting just almost
all hands oh my god can we do the finger
and intertwine anything oh wow this is
awesome
intimacy
interesting I don't want to get makes me
uncomfortable
stop it Steven McLoughlin you're a good
lad Sonny you and I we got to fight like
kangaroos some time getting goose
they're big in Ireland now I have the
right corner I hope that everything goes
okay I hope you don't go through too
many withdrawals because I know
Highbridge people they love to get
hammered they get drunk every day yeah
they get out of bowl of Lucky Charms and
pour some Jager into it and then [ __ ]
drink out of it and then they go to work
and then they drink more and then they
come home and they drink more they're
like come here hon a sock on my penis
they say penis there they don't say like
Coker Coker spaniel random and Andy's
channel new fan here shout-out please
you're a cool dude Ryan one question why
do I get boners for every girl I see
that you know that that you know that
are in your bids he just knows a lot of
cool chicks I know a lot of cool chicks
craigslist.org that's the place to go I
swear I'm a cat
that's where I met Melissa sadly enough
that's actually fact
look man yeah you have a YouTube channel
it's this simple okay find some girl
whatever Joan's be an actress bla bla
bla bla bla and then you just go up to
this and you say hey I have a YouTube
channel you should come on at some time
and then BAM [ __ ] on the bandwagon that
was insulting
was it really cuz you're not trying to
be an actress if you're trying to be an
actress that's like one of those things
that's like oh I do stuff all the time
but I'm really different day and I never
get paid no no actresses us girls on the
channel we do it we're real look us up
on IMDB yeah they they are actors yeah
seriously
are you really offended no no okay I am
seriously gonna be like scare the [ __ ]
out
Jesus random Anna you want advice and
look with his box man - I don't like
giving advice random Andy's channel yeah
so just tell girls you have a YouTube
channel that's not like a fun channel
name though random Andy's Channel
I think I'm gonna look you up watch your
videos yeah dude oh you can totally use
it to your avenge this is random Channel
so like a girl's in the makeup you can
be like oh that's funny I want to do a
little segment about Mako because those
[ __ ] zoom matters for random Jam
dumps on you can get a lot of Canary
this way could be random Andy's channel
I'm glad to have you as a new fan
remember girls they should come to you
you shouldn't have to go for them good
luck